States
thank you very much please very
importantly I'd like to begin by saying
that we've just reached agreement the
Secretary of Treasury Steve minuchin
with the major airlines all of our great
airlines to participate in a payroll
support program this agreement will
fully support airline industry workers
preserve the vital role airlines play in
our economy and protect taxpayers our
airlines are now in good shape and they
will get over a very tough period of
time that was not caused by them the
United States is continuing to make
substantial progress in our war against
the virus we grieve it every precious
life that has been lost to the invisible
enemy but through the darkness we can
see the rays of light we see that tunnel
and at the end of that tunnel we see
light we're starting to see it more than
ever before we've held our rate the
numbers everything we've done we've been
very very strong on it and very powerful
on it you look at what's happening in
other countries Spain Italy United
Kingdom we're working with them we're
trying to help them especially with
ventilators they've been calling a lot
they need ventilators so badly 15% of
counties within the United States have
zero cases and many counties within the
United States have a very small number
of cases large sections of our country
are really looking at other sections and
saying wow that looks bad but they don't
have the problem I salute the American
people for following our guidelines on
social distancing even you people is so
different looking out there when I look
at you their devotion you
devotion is saving lives today I'm
instructing my administration to halt
funding of the World Health Organization
while a review is conducted to assess
the World Health Organization's role in
severely mismanaging and covering up the
spread of the corona virus everybody
knows what's going on there American
taxpayers provide between 400 million
and 500 million dollars per year to the
w-h-o in contrast China contributes
roughly 40 million dollars a year and
even less as the organization's leading
sponsor the United States has a duty to
insist on full accountability one of the
most dangerous and costly decisions from
the WHL was its disastrous decision to
oppose travel restrictions from China
and other nations they were very much
opposed to what we did fortunately I was
not convinced and suspended travel from
China saving untold numbers of lives
thousands and thousands of people would
have died had other nations like Y
suspended travel from China countless
more lives would have been saved instead
look at the rest of the world look at
parts of Europe other nations and
regions who follow w-h-o guidelines and
kept their borders open to China
accelerated the pandemic all around the
world many countries said we're gonna
listen to the w-h-o and they have
problems the likes of which they cannot
believe nobody can believe the decision
of other major countries to keep travel
open was one of the great tragedies and
missed opportunities from the early days
the WHS attack on travel restrictions
put political correctness above
life-saving measures travel bans worked
for the same reason that quarantine work
pandemics depend on human to human
transmission border control is
fundamental to virus control
since its establishment in 1948 the
American people have generously
supported the World Health Organization
to provide better health outcomes for
the world and most importantly to help
prevent global health crises with the
outbreak of the kovat 19 pandemic we
have deep concerns whether America's
generosity has been put to the best use
possible the reality is that the w-h-o
failed to adequately obtain vet and
share information in a timely and
transparent fashion the world depends on
the WH o to work with countries to
ensure that accurate information about
international health threats is shared
in a timely manner and if it's not to
independently tell the world the truth
about what is happening the WH o failed
in this basic duty and must be held
accountable it's time after all of these
decades the wh o failed to investigate
credible reports from sources in Wuhan
that conflicted directly with the
Chinese government's official accounts
there was credible information to
suspect human to human transmission in
December 2019 which should have spurred
the w-h-o to investigate and investigate
immediately through the middle of
January it paired it and publicly
endorsed the idea that there was not
human to human transmission happening
despite reports and clear evidence to
the contrary the delays the w-h-o
experienced in declaring a public health
emergency cost valuable time tremendous
amounts of time more time was lost in
the delay it took to get a team of
international experts in to examine the
outbreak which we wanted to do which
they should have done the inability of
the w-h-o to obtain virus samples to
this date has deprived the scientific
community of essential data
new data that emerges across the world
when a daily basis points to the
unreliability of the initial reports and
the world received all sorts of false
information about transmission and
mortality The Silence of the w-h-o on
the disappearance of scientific
researchers and doctors and our new
restrictions on the sharing of research
into the origins of kovat 19 in the
country of origin is deeply concerning
especially when we put up by far the
largest amount of money not even close
had the w-h-o done its job to get
medical experts into china to
objectively assess the situation on the
ground and to call out china's lack of
transparency the outbreak could have
been contained at a source with very
little death very little death and
certainly very little death by
comparison this would have saved
thousands of lives and avoided worldwide
economic damage instead the WHL
willingly took china's assurances to
face value and they took it just at face
value and defended the actions of the
chinese government even praising China
for its so-called transparency I don't
think so the WHL pushed China's
misinformation about the virus saying it
was not communicable and there was no
need for travel bans they told us when
we put on our travel ban a very strong
travel band there was no need to do it
don't do it they actually fought us the
WHS reliance on China's disclosures
likely caused a 20-fold increase in
cases worldwide and it may be much more
than that
the WHL has not addressed a single one
of these concerns nor provided a serious
explanation that acknowledges its own
mistakes of which there were many
American the world have chosen
rely on the w-h-o for accurate timely
and independent information to make
important Public Health recommendations
and decisions if we cannot trust that
this is what we will receive from the
w-h-o our country will be forced to find
other ways to work with other nations to
achieve public health goals we'll have
no choice but to do that our countries
are now experiencing you look all over
the world
tremendous death and economic
devastation because those tasked with
protecting us by being truthful and
transparent failed to do so it would
have been so easy to be truthful and so
much death has been caused by their
mistakes we will continue to engage with
the w-h-o to see if it can make
meaningful reforms for the time being we
will redirect mobile health and directly
work with others all of the aid that we
send will be discussed at very very
powerful lettle letters and and with
very powerful and influential groups and
smart groups medically politically in
every other way and will be discussing
it with other countries and global
health partners what we do with all of
that money that goes to w-h-o and maybe
w-h-o will reform and maybe they won't
but we'll be able to see as you know in
other countries hit hard by the virus
hospitals have been tragically forced to
ration medical care and the use of
ventilators but due to our early and
aggressive action the skill of our
healthcare workers and the resilience of
our healthcare system no hospital in
America has been forced to deny any
patient access to a ventilator with all
of the talk you've heard where some
states wanted 40,000 ventilators I said
that doesn't work 40,000
and they ended up with seven or eight
thousand and they had no problem
forty thousand ventilators for one state
was ridiculous the scariest day of my
life was about a month ago when after a
long day of meetings my team told me
that we were going to be needing 130,000
ventilators that we were short hundreds
of thousands of ventilators this is the
system we inherited
I had governor's requesting unreasonable
sums that the federal government just
didn't have and you look at the states
the states didn't have the states were
not prepared I knew that every person
who needed a ventilator and didn't get
one would die and that's what we were
told they would die I saw in other
countries doctors having to make
decisions on who got a ventilator and
who didn't and I know that this would be
a defining challenge of the crisis those
that didn't get ventilators were said to
be in a position only of one alternative
and that was death would we be able to
prevent Americans from dying because we
couldn't get them ventilators and the
ventilators that they needed and they
need it immediately I instructed my team
to move heaven and earth to make sure
that this didn't happen we started to
smartly ration and distribute the
ventilators that we had and that others
had and I got daily updates on the
supply we had from requests coming in
and people wanting to have updates we
had a great group of people working on
it I instructed my team to use the
defense protection act and the defense
production act was used very powerfully
more powerfully than anybody would know
in fact so powerfully
that for the most part we didn't have to
officially take it out it was a hammer
it was a very powerful hammer in order
to manufacture as many ventilators as
possible
last year America manufactured from a
dead start 30,000 ventilators and this
year the number will be over a hundred
and fifty thousand ventilators it could
be as high as 200 thousand far more than
we'll ever need so we'll be able to
stockpile we'll be able to talk to
States about stockpiling these are high
quality ventilators we had a choice we
could do inexpensive less productive
ventilators or high quality we've done a
high quality ventilator so we should
have anywhere from 150 to 200 thousand
ventilators in addition to that we have
10,000 ventilators right now in the
federal stockpile ready to move should
we need them we might not should we need
them in New York or New Jersey or in
Louisiana or in Illinois or any other
state that may need them if we have a
search I'd like to ask Adam bowler to
come up and just say a few words he's
done a fantastic job young man who
worked 24 hours a day on handling this
situation and I just like to have have
Adam wherever he may be come up and say
a few words Adam please thank you very
much thank you thank you mr. president
at your direction this country has
worked hard over the past few weeks to
ramp up ventilator production through
all means possible
thousands of ventilators are coming in
now monthly with over a hundred thousand
by the end of June at the same time
there are over 60,000 ventilators and
our hospitals right now that are not in
use knowing this and at your direction
we reached out to the American Hospital
Association to design a system that
allows hospitals to lend ventilators to
other hospitals right when they need it
within the past week alone
20 top health systems have signed up for
this dynamic ventilator reserve
representing over 4000 ventilators not
only do we have top academic systems
like Cleveland Clinic and Mayo Clinic
but we also have top health systems from
New York City New Orleans Washington
State and California over a week ago
these places would have needed help but
now they are here to help
there's been no American that is needed
a ventilator that has not received one
this dynamic virtual reserve combined
with our strategic stockpile will ensure
that this is always the case I'd like to
thank the president for his leadership
and directive to focus on public-private
partnerships like this one I'd also like
to thank Sam Hazen from HCA Lloyd Dean
from common spirit for leading this
effort with the AJ and the Federation of
American hospitals these have been
difficult times a few weeks ago the Vice
President came into my office and he Ron
reminded us of the power of the
resilience of the American people and a
private companies we needed it that day
mr. vice president this partnership is
another example of Americans helping
Americans thank you thank you I'd shake
his hand but I'm not allowed to
times have changed haven't they thank
you very much you did a fantastic job
we're very proud of you you and your
whole team thank you today we are taking
further action to maximize our
oversupply and available ventilators
this afternoon I met with the leaders
the top people of many of America's big
powerful beautiful and you know very
very important hospitals and Hospital
associations who join us today I mean a
great meeting learned a lot and they've
been going through a lot they've been
doing a fantastic job as everybody here
will attest I'm pleased to announce that
my administration is partnering with the
hospitals across the country to create
an innovative new system called the
dynamic ventilator reserve so that we're
going to have tremendous numbers of
ventilators that we're able to help our
states with at a later date
if there's ever a problem like this
which we hope to God will never happen
again 1917 1918 that's a long time ago
we hope it never happens again and I'd
like to ask Rick [ __ ] of CEO of
American Hospital Association Sam Hayes
and CEO of HCA healthcare that's the
largest in the United States warner
thomas CEO of our health and if I could
my Hall you are you here from Cleveland
Clinic somebody good thank you come on
up folks please thank you say a few
words thank you very much mr. president
we appreciate the opportunity to work
with you and your team on the dynamic
ventilator reserve program this will
provide a really important mechanism for
us in serving our patients and
communities by ensuring that this vital
equipment will be available to critical
areas that are in need you know as this
battle against this disease has affected
the country a little bit unevenly the
rates of infection hospitalization in
ICU use varies from one region to
another in some places with lower
infection rates some ventilators may not
be in use while other areas are
potentially stretched beyond their
capacity the database of available
ventilators that we are creating will
allow us to flex so that we can make
sure that available equipment can be
shared with those in need we appreciate
the leadership of the health systems
that are here today that has stepped
forward and Adam mentioned a few I don't
know if he caught dr. Fritz Francois
from NYU Langone and David ill the CEO
of Life point as well we appreciate the
work of the administration in helping us
find innovative solutions
to ensure the best care for our patients
we'll continue to work with hospitals
and health systems across the country to
add to this reserve further your
teammates provided us with important
leadership and we look forward to
working with you in making this a
success Thank You mr. president thank
you
Thank You mr. president mr. vice
president Adam the team I stand here
before you you in front of our 285,000
colleagues who provide care to patients
every day across the country one of the
guiding principles we had when we went
into this Cove ignite teen battle was to
find partnerships partnerships with
other components of the industry
partnerships with other health systems
but partnerships with governments both
local and federal and we're proud to be
a part of this private public sector
partnership and I think it's going to do
great good for the community so thank
you very much Thank You mr. president
it's it's great to have auktioner health
be part of this program we certainly
have been a a recipient and the state of
Louisiana has been a recipient of help
getting ventilators to our state and to
auktioner health we're currently taking
care of about 60% of the kovat patients
in New Orleans and we did see a spike
over the past few weeks but we're
starting to get on the other side of
that and heading in the right direction
I also want to thank you personally for
helping auction or health a couple weeks
ago we're running short on surgical
gowns and you and your team were able to
direct some to New Orleans which was
helpful to us and other hospitals around
the New Orleans area so we're excited to
be part of this dynamic ventilator
Reserve and we are proud to be part of
that and help other communities around
the country thank you Thank You mr.
president for the invitation here on
behalf of the Cleveland Clinic I would
just like to offer a slightly different
story about a covert pandemic in our
home state of Ohio with an early
institution of social distancing our
ability to scale up the testing and
ramping out the capacity we have
actually seen a stable number of
patients over the last eight to ten days
only hundred and sixty patients have
been hospitalized with kovat infection
in Cleveland Clinic Health System we are
also very grateful for the support from
our state government as well from
federal government this is a battle
where we're all in together we
coordinate our efforts share our
resources and work together as one I'm
firmly convinced that we can do a lot of
good when we work together thank you
very much for having us thank you sir
that was a terrific meeting and thank
you all for being here thank you very
much the United States has far more ICU
beds per capita than any other nation we
have 34.7 ICU beds per 100,000 people
which is the best there is
compared with roughly 12.5 beds per
100,000 in Italy 11.6 beds in France 9.7
beds in Spain think of that 34.7 we have
and 6.6 in the UK there are more than
60,000 ventilators at hospitals and
other health care facilities that are
not in use at this moment they didn't
need them we got a lot of them out and
they didn't need them and that's a good
thing that they didn't need him but a
lot of good brainpower was involved in
making a lot of fantastic decisions I
want to thank our vice president for the
task force and I want to thank all
members of your Task Force on having
done an incredible job you really have
done an incredible job thank you Mike
very much through this new partnership
with the hospitals unused ventilators
will voluntarily lend them where they
have unused ventilators they will
voluntary lend those ventless to other
hospitals and other areas of greater
need within the last several days more
than 20 of our nation's largest health
systems have already pledged more than
4,000 ventilators should we need them
and I've been told that if they need
more there are more
there we're going to be helping very
soon when the supply really starts
pouring in which is which started but
will really start about less than a
month we're going to be helping other
countries and they need it very badly if
they have no chance without these
ventilators they have to have
ventilators as we continue our medical
war against the virus the FDA has now
authorized the first test developed by
researchers from Rutgers University that
can use saliva from patients the first
one these tests can be self administered
by patients and healthcare settings
which will reduce exposure for medical
workers and save personal protective
equipment Rutgers will begin processing
ten thousand tests daily so by using
saliva that's the first they'll be able
to do things in terms of speed and ease
that we haven't been able to do before
so a lot of great innovation is taking
place during this period of time and
that's innovation I call it innovation
under pressure it's a big difference
innovation under pressure right
Cleveland Clinic knows all about that as
we prepare for the next phase of this
great struggle we must also do
everything in our power to restore
prosperity for the American worker
there's tremendous interest and
excitement surrounding the
administration's efforts to get the
economy roaring once again and I think
it's going to roar once it gets open I
think it's going to go up tremendously
you see what's happening with the stock
market already because a lot of the very
smart financial people the great minds
they're looking at the stock and they're
saying well because they really what
they're really seeing is how we're doing
if we weren't doing well the market
wouldn't be at a level that it is today
they have a lot of confidence that we're
doing the right thing and that our
country is going to be open soon and our
country is going to be booming we've had
requests to participate from the best in
the world as we share their enthusiasm
to get our country going so I think
them for wanting to contribute and we
look forward to speaking with many
industry leaders seeking their input on
how we can return to what was until very
recently the greatest economy anywhere
in the world and I can say the greatest
economy in the history of the world has
never been an economy like we had just a
little bit more than a month ago we said
every record you could set more people
working than we've ever had working
before almost 160 million the best
unemployment numbers we've ever had and
the best employment numbers we've ever
had everybody was doing well stock
market at a record 142 days that hit a
record and I think we're going to top
those records okay and I think we're
going to top them soon once we get rid
of the invisible enemy which will happen
the plans to reopen the country are
close to being finalized and we will
soon be sharing details and new
guidelines with everybody I will be
speaking to all 50 governors very
shortly and I will then be authorizing
each individual governor of each
individual state to implement a
reopening and a very powerful reopening
plan of their state at a time and in a
manner as most appropriate the day will
be very close because certain states as
you know are in much different condition
and in a much different place than other
states it's going to be very very close
maybe even before the date of May 1st so
that will be for some states actually
there are over 20 that are in extremely
good shape and we think we're going to
be able to get them open fairly quickly
and then others will follow the federal
government will be watching them very
closely and
we'll be there to help we'll be there to
help in many different ways as we've
been where we built hospital beds at a
number that nobody's ever seen before
where we did the ventilators that we
just discussed at a level that nobody's
ever seen before nobody can even believe
other foreign countries even powerful
countries can't believe what we were
able to do with ventilators big powerful
countries big producing countries can't
believe what we were able to do we will
hold the governors accountable but again
we're going to be working with them to
make sure it works really well now we
have a list of people that I'll be
speaking to over the next very short
period of time in many cases tomorrow
we're going to have elected officials
and we'll be submitting that list to you
within the next 24 hours but we have a
list of different industries that I'll
be discussing by meeting by telephone
because we don't want people traveling
right now the American Farm Bureau
Federation zippy Duvall Cisco Systems
Tyson Foods Perdue farms Cargill Archer
Daniels Midland company Cort Eva tractor
supply company seaboard Corporation
Grimm way Farms Mount Ayr Farms and
others in the agricultural business and
banking it's Bank of America Brian
Moynihan has been great JP Morgan Chase
Jamie Dimon Goldman Sachs Citigroup
Wells Fargo US Bancorp Morgan Stanley
James Gorman Grand Rapids State Bank
Southern Bank Corp all great
institutions with lots to say and lots
of good ideas and if you look at how
paycheck has been working out the
numbers are incredible and I hope
Congress is going to be able to
supplement the amount of money going to
our workers I hope they're able to get
that done very quickly because it's been
an incredible success and many are
already spending
that money and the money's been
distributed at numbers that nobody
believed possible for this short period
of time was only a week ago but a lot of
money has been distributed already it's
going to keep our small businesses open
the construction labor workforce
International Union of Operating
Engineers Jim Callahan North America
Building Trades Union Sean mcGarvie is
there a lot of friends of mine laborers
International Union of North America
Terry O'Sullivan International
Brotherhood of Teamsters James Hoffa
National Electrical Contractors
Association David long Bechtel Fleur
National Association of Home Builders
Association of Builders and Contractors
associated general contractor's Richard
Trumka AF of l-cio G H Palmer so these
are some of the union's pretty much
almost all of the ones that will be on
the line in defense we have Lockheed
Martin Honeywell Northrop Grumman these
are all the top of each company CEOs
Chairman's presidents Raytheon General
Dynamics Energy we had a tremendous
success recently with energy over the
weekend it finished with tremendous
credit going to Russia and Saudi Arabia
and it could be as much as 20 million
barrels a day a cut so we can get rid of
some of the tremendous excess oil that's
been produced because of the fact that
the virus just knocked out almost 50% of
the business it's been an amazing
achievement
some people say one of the biggest oil
deals ever made maybe the biggest oil
deal ever made they're saying I didn't
know that but we were involved in
getting that done and it was very
important we're going to save hundreds
of thousands of jobs for our energy
industry Texas and North Dakota Oklahoma
all of our different energy states it's
great so we're very happy about it I
want to thank everybody we had the it's
called OPEC plus that's
OPEC Plus meaning some nations outside
of OPEC and I also want to thank the
President of Mexico because he was he
was terrific you showed great dexterity
and flexibility and getting the deal
done we want to thank him very much on
the energy front we had Exxon Mobil
Continental Resources Chevron Southern
Company Alabama Power ConocoPhillips
Occidental Petroleum kind of Morgan Tess
corporation Perot group and few others
big ones great ones financial services
we have Blackstone Stephen Schwarzman
Paulson and company John Paulson Citadel
Ken Griffin Elliott Management Paul
singer Vista Equity Partners Robert
Smith fidelity investments Abigail
Johnson MasterCard Visa Chubb Sequoia
Stevens Warren Stevens great Charles
Schwab Chuck Schwab will be here by
phone food and beverage National
Restaurant Association McDonald's Darden
Restaurants coca-cola pepsi-cola
chick-fil-a Subway bloomin brands Yum
Brands Papa John's Wendy's Waffle House
Starbucks Wolfgang Puck Thomas Keller is
young George my friend John George and
Danielle you know them from the
transportation world FedEx Fred Smith a
legend United Airlines Oscar Munoz UPS
David Abney JB Hunt YRC Worldwide
Crowley maritime credible big powerful
shippers and transportation companies in
telecommunications we have the legendary
John Malone of Liberty Media Verizon
t-mobile Charter Communications
and Brian Roberts of Comcast thank you
all very much healthcare new
york-presbyterian Gerry spire friend of
mine HCA healthcare Sam Hazen thank you
Sam
just met with Sam ascension health
common spirit health community health
systems Trinity Health Cardinal health
my Kissin 3m thank you Mike Roman for
helping us with face masks that worked
out well for everybody
Procter and Gamble Abbott Laboratories
Johnson & Johnson Merck Pfizer Eli Lilly
Thermo Fisher Scientific they've been
helping us incredibly with testing
Gilead Sciences Abbey vie Regeneron
Biogen Roche and Rocha has been
fantastic on testing the job they've
done I have to call them out they have
really they have stepped up like very
few Anthem United Health Group at Cigna
and Humana all the big ones the tech
companies we have the right ones Apple
we have Tim Cook Google sundar Thank You
sundar Oracle Larry Ellison and Safra
Catz Salesforce mark been enough sa
piece Happ Jen Morgan Microsoft's Satya
great job he's done
thank you such Facebook Mark Zuckerberg
IBM Intel Qualcomm Cisco Advanced Micro
Devices Broadcom incredible companies
companies that no other country will
catch if they're smart they have to be
smart but I've dealt with a lot of
different countries and I will say that
know the respect for Silicon Valley and
our tech companies there's nobody even
close to our tech companies they can't
catch them so they try and buy them
but we sort of put an end to a lot of
that in sports we want to get our sports
back so importantly these will be some
separate calls some will be together by
the way lists and some will be separate
but we have to get our sports back I'm
tired of watching baseball games at a 14
years old but I haven't actually had too
much time to watch I would say maybe I
watched one batter and then I get back
to work the NBA Adam Silver the major
league baseball we miss our base whether
this is baseball season right here Rob
Manfred thank you very much NFL Roger
Goodell Thank You Roger
UFC Dana White great Dana White PGA Jay
Moynihan LPGA Michael Juan USDA Patrick
Galbraith Major League Soccer Don Garber
WWE the great Vince McMahon NASCAR Lisa
Kennedy thank you Lisa
NHL Gary Bettman from the New England
Patriots Bob Kraft Dallas Cowboys Jerry
Jones Dallas Mavericks Mark Cuban and
some of the thought leaders that we're
going to have and there are some others
that we are having with just waiting to
hear but everybody's saying yes I must
say John Ellison Heritage Foundation K
called James great person Hoover
Institute Condoleezza Rice another great
person art Laffer Steve Moore Steve
Forbes Larry Lindsey Catherine Reynolds
Scott Gottlieb just spoke with Scott Jim
DeMint and Jim has been terrific friend
Bill Haggerty and Ray Washburn and
religious leaders will be coming on
Friday we'll be speaking to and on what
we're going to have a separate list but
we have tremendous enthusiasm to meet by
our great religious leaders we have
incredible people and they want to they
want to be a poor
and we'll be talking about churches and
we'll be talking about opening and we'll
be talking about things that are very
important to a lot of people including
me we're gonna find out how we're doing
in that regard so those are the names
that we have on our lists
they're the names that are I think the
best and the smartest the brightest and
they're gonna give us some ideas but
we're all set as I said the governors
are going to be opening up their states
they're going to declare when they're
going to know when some can open very
very shortly if not almost immediately
we'll give a date but the dates going to
be in the very near future so we'll get
it open individual states when the
governors will be held accountable if
they need things we'll help them get
those things but we want them to do
their testing we want them because
they're equipped to do testing we've
created incredible tests and we've done
more testing than anybody's ever done in
the world right now and we we had a
broken system and now we have a great
system we have a system where other
countries are coming to us and saying we
want to get some of those tests
I want to thank Abbott because Abbott
came up with the first simpler test the
first was rough if you were I think it
was more of an operation than a test the
first one was for anybody that took it
it was not easy but now we have a very
simple test with Abbott now we have
saliva we have lots of other things that
are happening but we have millions of
tests the governors are responsible they
have to take charge they have to do a
great job and we're going to suggest
that they check people through tests or
otherwise coming into their states and
they run their States very strong
eventually we won't have to do that
eventually this will be gone but for a
while we're going to do it so they're
going to take charge at their borders
they're going to take charge of people
coming in and maybe to an extent
depending on what they work out with a
nearby state it may be also people
leaving and they'll be able to do that
very shortly we'll be announcing a date
but it'll be very short and frankly
it'll be at a time that will be
earlier than the deadlines that we
opposed the end of April so we think
that some of the governor's will be in
really good shape to open up even sooner
than that we'll speak to them but we're
all set who are counting on the
governor's to do a great job others are
gonna have to take a longer period of
time until they're in a position to say
we're ready to go and that's okay we
understand that some of the governor's
have a very tough situation but in
almost all cases it's all starting to
come down we're very proud of the job
everybody's done and if you look at the
numbers
so the minimum as you as portrayed
deborah's here dr. Brooks has been
fantastic the minimum was a hundred
thousand deaths and I hope to be
substantially under the minimum meaning
we all hope Mike right we all hope to be
substantially under we did the right
thing because otherwise it would have
been the projections are two million
people the actual projection was 2.2
million people and if you cut it in half
that would be 1.1 million people that's
many more that's double the Civil War
then if you cut that in half you're
talking five or six hundred thousand
people that's what we lost in the Civil
War and that's cutting it cutting it
cutting it and we're not going to that
would not be acceptable who would not be
acceptable nothing's that one life isn't
acceptable but we weren't given that
option so I'm confident that these
respected people that I just read from
the list will give us some great ideas
in addition to what the governor's have
learned the governors have learned a lot
I've spoken to governor's that at the
beginning it was a contentious
relationship and now it's a very
friendly relationship and a really great
relationship and I'm proud to say that
some of them I think are friends in some
cases they're Democrats but I think they
like me and I actually like them I'll
tell you who they are someday but we're
all getting along and we all want to do
the right thing and I think they're
going to do a great job of leading their
individual states it'll be a beautiful
thing to watch
still go and rely on their mayors and
their local town officials they bring it
right down and Washington shouldn't be
doing that we can't be thinking about a
Walmart parking lot that's 2,000 miles
away well we're doing testing but a
governor of a state can an American and
write down on the line so it's gonna be
I think it's gonna be a terrific system
and if we're unhappy with the state
we're going to let them know we're and
happy and if they're not doing the job
and they can't get the job done and for
some reason things are happening that
we're not gonna like like the numbers
are heading in a wrong direction
we'll have to do something that's very
very serious we'll have to maybe close
them up and start all over again but I
don't think we're gonna have to do that
I think the governors are going to come
out at a time that and these will be
individual dates and the governors are
going to come out at a time when they're
ready someone can come out very very
shortly and we look forward to watching
that process I think it's going to be a
very beautiful process our discussions
will focus with the people that we're
dealing with on rejuvenating the economy
and always health always health health
and life living is number one but the
rejuvenated economy and I think it's
going to go quickly will be utilizing
our robust testing capacity for the
governors will be giving them what they
need if they don't have it themselves we
hope by now they'll be able to have it
themselves we were hoping they would
have had it themselves early on but they
weren't but such great advances have
been made so we'll be dealing with them
on that and we they can rely on us very
strongly they're going to be relying on
us I think for some help and we're there
whether it's building hospital beds
which I don't think they're going to
need you look at Javits Center a great
great job that the Army Corps of
Engineers did FEMA got involved we
actually ended up sending our medical
people that was not a kovat 19 Center
and they asked could you do that and
then even after we did that it was not
used very much meaning they didn't have
to use it nearly to the extent that they
thought when they conceived it it wasn't
that they made a mistake
nobody made a mistake we built it I'd
rather have too much than too little
err on the side of caution and its
really incredible what they did
including the two ships the two great
ships and I just want to thank a lot of
really great people a lot of great
politicians and again we're going to be
announcing the political list tomorrow
and on there we're going to have a lot
of senators and we're going to be having
a meeting with the governors probably on
Thursday a meeting by teleconference and
a lot of things will be discussed and
some of the details will be in discussed
but we want them to do an incredible job
of running their States I think they'll
do an incredible job too after having
gotten to know so many of them I think
each one of them will do an incredible
job and again the federal government is
there we have ventilators if they need
them we have beds if they need a way of
hospitals if they need them we have a
testing capacity that's now second to
none where again other countries are
calling us countries that you thought
were doing well are calling us for help
on testing so we're there to help and
with that if you have a few questions
we'll take them and if not that would be
okay too yeah go ahead please chef mr.
president two questions first I
understand your grievances with them can
you address why it is the correct time
to do this well we're going to be
dealing with countries and we're going
to be dealing with leaders of different
parts of the world we spend 500 million
a year we have for many years more far
more than anybody else including China
and I mean look I read off a long list
of problems that we have and we've had
problems with them for years
it doesn't matter we're looking at a
term of 60 to 90 days we're doing a very
thorough investigation right now as we
speak but this should have been done by
previous administrations a long time ago
and when you look at the mistakes that
were made all of the mistakes that were
made it's just something we have to look
at and it is very China centric I told
that to President Xi I said the world
Health Organisation is very china
centric meaning whatever it is China was
always right you can't do that can't do
that not right and we spend it again
it's not a question of money but when
we're spending five hundred million
dollars and China's spending thirty
eight million 34 million 40 million
forty-two million in a case it's again
not money but it's not right so we'll
see this is an evaluation period but in
the meantime we're putting a hold on all
funds going to world health we will be
able to take that money and channel it
to the areas that most need it and
that's another way of doing it but we
have not been treated properly you
mentioned that you're going to be
speaking with the all the governors yes
what if they don't listen to you or take
your advice or obey you will you will
you consider taking away their federal
funding I don't want to say that they'll
listen
they'll be fine I think we're going to
have a good relationship they need the
federal government not only for funding
and I'm not saying take it away but they
need it for advice they'll need maybe
equipment that we have we have a
tremendous stockpile that we're in the
process of completing we're in a very
good position again the cupboard was
bare when I got here nobody ever thought
a thing in all fairness to previous
administrations nobody ever thought
anything like this was going to happen
but it did happen now the governor's
will be very very respectful of the
presidency again this isn't me this is
the presidency the presidency has such a
great importance in terms of what we're
doing and you can talk about
Constitution you can talk about
federalism you can talk about whatever
you want but the best way I'm talking
now from a managerial standpoint is to
let individual governors run individual
states and come to us if they have
difficulty and we will help them yeah
John you talk about having testing and
tracing equipment
the and the facility for that in place
to open up the government doctor fancy
said this morning that that critical
testing and tracing ability does not
currently exist
I don't know well my question is will
Adina's my question is will it exist by
May 1st the individual governors have
testing the individual governor's we
have many forms of testing and new
testing is being developed our country
has to get opened and it will get open
and it'll get open safely and hopefully
quickly some areas quicker than other
areas but there's tremendous testing and
the governor's will use whatever testing
is necessary and if they're not
satisfied with their testing they
shouldn't open but they'll use
whatever's testing whatever testing is
necessary go ahead Thank You mr.
president back to the WH o will you
support the organization again if Ted
Rose is immediately replaced or do you
want to see him step down as possible
well we're doing an investigation I I
don't know the gentleman but I know
there have been problems and it's been
very unfair to the United States just
like the World Trade Organization has
been very very unfair and now they're
coming into line when they consider
China a developing nation and because
China is a developing nation they take
massive advantage of the United States
why did another president stop this I've
been talking about it from the day I got
in and we're looking at that very very
strongly World Trade W so I have problem
with world health and world trade both
of them I'm not sure which is worse you
one another truth but we'll figure it
out okay mr. president
praising China is transparent but you're
seeing many of the same things about
China just a couple of months ago so I
mean how do you square your decisions
well I didn't trade deal with China what
China is supposed to be spending 250
billion dollars in our country we're
going to be watching very much to see
now what got a little bit waylaid by the
virus but look I'd love to have a good
relationship with China but if you look
and we made a phenomenal deal China has
paid because of me China has paid us
tens of billions of dollars over the
course of a very short period of time
billions of it some of that money has
been spent to farmers where they were
targeted by China we cannot let that
happen we can't let that happen
so we ended up signing a very good trade
deal now I want to see if China lives up
to it I know President Xi I think you
will live up to it if he doesn't live up
to it that will be okay too because we
have very very good alternatives no you
wanna blame the WHL but I spoke at a
hundreds of people across the country in
the last few weeks who say they still
can't get tested and that they aren't
social distancing because I know I know
you question you ready the governor's
the governors are supposed to do testing
it's up to the governor's go ahead
governors are doing the testing it's now
not up and it hasn't been up to the
federal government go ahead put this guy
here it's nothing but trouble he's a
showboat if you keep talking I'll leave
and you could have it out with the rest
of these people if you keep talking I'm
gonna leave and you can have it out with
them just a loudmouth
go ahead governor's are gonna be running
their individual states some of them
will say no I can't open now and some of
them may last longer than we even would
think others will say I can you can go I
don't want to mention States but there
are numerous states that are in great
shape right now they're viewing the rest
of the country like we don't even
believe this is happening we have a lot
of those states they're set to open
practically now I mean they would be
open now we're gonna let them open
sooner than the date we're gonna pick a
date we're gonna get a date that's good
but it's going to be very very soon
sooner
than the end of the month but there are
many states out there that are looking
at this and they're reviewing it and
they're saying we shouldn't be even
included in this you know there's some
that want to open up almost now now if
we disagree with it we're not gonna let
them open we're not gonna let them open
if some governor said you know has a lot
of problems a lot of cases a lot of
death and they want to open early we're
not going to let it happen
so we're there to watch we're there to
help but we're also there to be critics
and on testing very important we've
always wanted the states to do the
testing we're now providing great
testing but the state has to provide the
great testing the state has to provide
the ventilators but they didn't do that
so we ended up going into the ventilator
business essentially and we've made tens
of thousands of ventilators and we
solved the big problem for the states
but we want them to do the testing and
we are there to help I'm respectful of
other countries why wouldn't I be
respectful of China in the meantime
China has paid us nothing in your last
administration nothing in any previous
administration they paid us tens of
billions of dollars because of what
we've done and the trade deal we have
they have to give us two hundred and
fifty billion dollars in purchases let's
see if they do that and they're also
paying us twenty five percent or two
hundred and fifty billion dollars in
tariffs so we're taking in women we take
it in billions of dollars for China from
China they never paid us ten cents
that's a great thing now if they don't
produce or if we find out bad things
we're not going to be happy but right
now and and we're doing that that's what
we're doing look we have an
investigation underway we're paying
almost 500 million dollars we have an
investigation underway on the World
Health Organization we will find out
exactly what we're
and we may be satisfied that it could be
remedied and we may be said of satisfied
that it's so bad that it can't be
remedied and if it can't we're going to
go a different route praising China for
being transparent but you also praised
China for being transparent I don't talk
about China's transparency well you know
if I'm so good to China how come I was
the only person the only leader of a
country that closed our borders tightly
against China and by the way when I
closed our border that was long ahead of
what anybody you can ask anybody that
was in the room 21 people I was the one
person that wanted to do it
Debra can tell you that better than
anybody I was the one person that wanted
to do it you know why because I don't
believe everything I hear and I closed
and if we didn't close our border early
very early long before the kind of dates
you're talking about we would have had
thousands and probably hundreds of
thousands more death please yes we
worked on very strong I would say within
two weeks and it's being worked on
Deborah we're working on that very
strongly
okay CTC is working but we're getting
reports on that yes we may not you know
some countries have in some countries
haven't I'm watching other countries I'm
studying other countries as they open I
mean I don't want to go into names
because for some it would be a little
bit embarrassing but I'm studying other
countries as we go along so on that we
have looked at every country that's
opened some successfully some okay no
total disaster but some okay and some
have to go back to the hot spot and fix
the hot spot we think we're going to do
it very successfully again we have one
country but we have lots of different
pieces it's a puzzle we have beautiful
pieces beautiful states with capable
governor's they know when it's time to
open and we don't want to put pressure
in anybody I'm not going to put any
pressure
on any governor to open I'm not going to
say to Governor Cuomo you got to open
within seven days I want him to take his
time do it right and then open New York
I'm not putting any pressure on the
governor's some of them don't need
pressure or not pressure I mean they're
ready to they're ready to go and that's
a good thing so we'll open it up in
beautiful little pieces as it comes
along please go ahead that were New York
to be pressured to be open it would be a
constant cause a constitutional crisis
and P basically said that you declared
yourself king myself as king you know I
heard he said that but I didn't I didn't
see the remarks but he understands how
we helped him he needed help we gave him
two thousand nine hundred hospital beds
he didn't use them we gave him a ship he
didn't use him and I'm not saying but
I'm saying that's good because you know
what that means he didn't need him but
we said it was too much but we wanted to
air we said earn the set of question as
I said we said look we don't think you
need it but if you do we're gonna have
him built and the Army Corps of
Engineers did a fantastic job and the US
Navy did a fantastic job when we moved
the ship that was not meant for kovat
and we had it redesigned for kovat but
they still didn't have very many people
going in now
we are we'll get along just fine he
understands polka plays louder
what's your assurance the workers
are asked to go back to work but are
fearful of doing so well that's gonna be
up to the governor's the governor's are
gonna want to make sure everything's
safe now I think that companies can do
testing on a maybe weekly basis you have
to do it every day with the same worker
but they can do testing they could do
temperature gauges they could do a lot
of different things and you know we're
only talking about for a period of time
you know eventually we want to get back
to where we were we want people actually
sitting next to each other in ball games
eventually you know we're not going to
rip out every every other seat in
baseball stadiums and football stadiums
we want to go back to where we were I
want people to understand that we're not
going to be like the way you are we have
300 reporters in the back that want to
say look at the look at this the way
this looks I don't even like the way it
looks although I have a lot fewer
reporters that's okay with me but look
at the way this looks I've never seen
anything John I've never seen anything
quite like it
but there are a lot of people we don't
want this I don't want this I don't want
this eventually we're going back we're
restaurants that had 150 seats are going
to have a hundred and fifty seats not 50
seats because they can't make it at 50
seats but more importantly the
atmosphere is even better we have to get
used to it we have to get used to it I
don't know that people are gonna be
shaking hands as readily
some will I said to some of the hospital
people today so well people be shaking
hands again and I must say I was a
little surprised most of them said
probably because there is some kind of a
thing to it I was never a big hand
shaker but when I ran for politics I
said I think I better start shaking
people's hand go ahead John mr.
president a couple of financial
questions if I could
Larry Kudlow said this morning that the
current run rate the paycheck protection
money will run out very soon plan to
re-up it you stalled in Congress what
can you do as president truck to try to
move that forward well we're trying to
get it done the problem is the Democrats
want to put all sorts of things less
time to put Kennedy Center and I hated
putting Kennedy Center and I've great
respect for Kennedy Center but I hated
putting it in the bill because it's just
not appropriate right and but they
wanted it in for whatever reason they
had their own political reason and John
I said watch the way that blows up and
it blew up I think it blew up in their
face
we want to take
workers will worry about other things
and other pet projects of Democrats and
also Republicans later but it's been a
tremendously successful program I think
you see if they banks have stepped up
hundreds of thousands of loan
applications approved money is going out
it's been a tremendous program really
has been and obviously it was at a point
where we're almost you know we're almost
the money will be expired and we could
use a refill for the workers we want to
be able to make sure that small
businesses stay open John and I think
that will happen I'm a first but there
are 20 states actually I was given a
number twenty-nine states are in very
very good shape I don't want to say
whether or not the governor spoke with
me about that but we've had a very good
relationship gavin newsom and a very
very good relationship yeah in the back
go ahead close that there's a danger
that there that the food supply could be
interrupted during this endemic and i
wanted to know what you're going to do
about well I think our farmers are
incredible they're producing levels of
food like just unbelievable our
transportation that's one of the reasons
I have the transportation people on the
line tomorrow for the delivery of the
food now we're doing phenomenally with
the food and I will say the stores
Kroger and Walmart which has a lot of
the food and and many of the stores they
seem to be in very good shape but I
haven't heard that at all will there be
very strong on food supply
okay how about one more question yes the
the death projections that you mentioned
earlier are based on full social
distance
until the end of them so if you ease up
on these guidelines now how many more
Americans do you think first of all
we'll have guidelines even for the
states that open and there'll be
guidelines but we will not have any
problem with that where your questions a
very interesting question but the states
that are opening are not states which
will have a problem with that plus they
will have to adhere to guidelines until
a certain point into the future when the
enemy is vanquished the reason they
don't have a problem now is because of
social distancing so if you only don't
have is partially and some of that will
stay in effect much of it will stay in
effect for a period of time but the
reason also is that different kinds of
states they have lots of room they have
fewer people and they have lots of room
and that's one of the primary reasons I
want to thank you all very much so a lot
of positive things are happening we're
gonna have some very strong
recommendations for the governor's we're
going to work with the governor's the
governor's are going to do a good job
and if they don't do a good job we're
going to come down on them very hard
we'll have no other choice thank you all
very much thank you thank you